major incident being declared in the
channel some detail emerging
particularly around the scale of the
rescue effort that that is pretty
alarming and we have a statement from a
marine and Coast Guard agency spokesman
which says this his Majesty's Coast
Guard is currently coordinating a search
and rescue response to an incident
involving a small boat off Kent they say
that they're working with the Navy
border Force Kent Police and other
partners they have sent Dover Dungeness
Hastings and Ramsgate lifeboats they
have also sent deal Dungeness and
Folkston Coast Guard rescue teams along
with the Coast Guard area commander an
awful lot of effort is being put into
this quite clearly helicopters uh from
the solent one from the French navy are
also involved and a fishing vessel in
the area also assisting with the rescue
uh the Southeast coast ambulance and
Kent Police working with them an air
ambulance is also on the scene the
statement concludes by saying the
incident is ongoing